evidently Sal bought me a birthday gift
you know about this well yeah so this
morning he runs up to Jason is it's a
wrapped gift yeah so with the wrapping
paper and a card he goes I have a
birthday gift for Howard like oh well
his birthday was five days ago he said I
have it now and I said okay like why is
it your problem right so he goes to me
what should I do with it I bet you take
it I don't know like we've been over the
scary used to give me he'd hand me a
gift while we were here and I go Gary
now I got to get this thing [ __ ] home
so it's all says to me should I ask Gary
what to do and I said yes please go ask
Gary what to do get away from me so
Jason pawned Sal off on Gary and goes go
ask Gary yeah I usually do ask Gary Gary
what happened when style ask you what
you don't know you're the produce of the
show for over 30 years and you doesn't
know what to do you've never heard me
say do you know what it is you want to
show everyone you got the boss I've done
this every year yes I did very nervous
pacing and it starts to give me this
long explanation of why they kept us
late at sell what did I say to you you
said put it down though I said I don't
care I had it delivered that's why I'm
telling me because you're the producer
you jackass I'm telling you how a gift
is late why do I care what does he need
to hear that story
not that it's late it was two seconds it
was in passing what is Gary care he's in
the middle of doing whatever it is he
does nothing no he's doing stuff he
wasn't you walking hey Gary guess what I
ordered a game panda came late and he
like yelled at forgiving somebody for
having some you don't know my dreadful
yes but I figured today you could take
it it would take it so now I got a walk
around this yeah you know it's some book
I'm never gonna read first I'm gonna
read it you never heard that I read
books on Kindle this is different it's a
different it's not a kindle to whether
you can teach me how to paint let me
guess it there's something involved if
you think you can learn how to paint
from a [ __ ] book these are tricks and
techniques over the years and here's the
gift [ __ ]
bring in the Sun just I'm gonna open it
up bring it out I appreciate the
sentiment it's very nice of you but I'm
never gonna look at this [ __ ] book I
haven't even opened it yet let me see it
[ __ ] this maybe it is a great book yeah
thank you know it's not let me warn
anybody who's thinking of taking up the
life up to be an expert in painting or
anything I know how much painting means
to you so I spent a lot of time
researching something that I think would
apply to Oh
masking materials don't you think I know
how to mask I think you do but there's
always something that could be learned
by the way you should taught the guy
because Gary does seem still confused by
this whole what we're allowed to bring
into work and what we're not allowed to
bring it what is Gary because I said to
Gary that one of the things we should
boss all about is that he brought the
gift physically and to get to you knows
I don't want to carry this big [ __ ]
book home guy goes no no no no it's
totally okay to bring the stuff into
work because there's a system to get at
the Howard now don't plan anything to
work Gary don't give me a gift
[ __ ] Gary used to hand me his
Christmas party handed to me all right
so bring this to my house Gary between
deliver like a dog first of all yes
unite a millionaire I know that I don't
want you don't spend money on me it
wasn't much at all but yeah I could tell